I'm 18 I'm a freshman at UNCC and I'm
studying Business and Entrepreneurship I
own my own business and I've been having
difficulties being able to do a good job
both running my business and also doing
a good job in school what's your
business we are an event entertainment
company we specialize in balloon animals
and face paint this past year we were
able to make over 25,000 great and
that's net profit
yes yes wonderful and you're saying hey
this is a lot for me to run while I'm in
college you've got school you've got the
business and you've got a social life it
doesn't sound like you can do all three
of those to the level that you want so
you got to start going okay let me
reverse engineer this what's most
important long term and that's going to
determine what's most important in the
short term